ce que vous plaidez depuis des mois et
des mois le ce que le Québec plaide
c'est que c'était trop là il y en avait
trop exactement la capacité d'accueil du
Québec avait été dépassé parce qu'il y
avait un afflux trop important et qui
est non planifié ces gens c'est 40 000
demandeurs d'asile on n'avait pas prévu
qui s'en viendrait en plus de manière
très concentrée sur mon Réal donc ça
crée une pression importante à la fois
sur nos services gouvernementaux on peut
penser aux hôpitaux également au système
d'éducation mais à la fois également sur
les organismes qui accueillent qui
accompagnent ces immigrants et
d'ailleurs je les remercie parce que
vraiment ils ont déployé l'un des
efforts colossaux pour vraiment réagir
adéquatement à cette afflux important on
va revenir au crânes des gens qui sont
près de de ce milieu de l'immigration
des réfugiés mais d'abord sur le
l'accord même on dit que c'était prêt il
y a un an presque donc
le gouvernement le groupe peut pas dire
c'est parce qu'on a fait une campagne et
puis des LEDs que ça a marché il y avait
un projet d'accord depuis un bout de
temps c'est ce qu'on comprend
aujourd'hui nous à moi on ne m'a jamais
communiqué cette information là j'ai eu
des contacts fréquents avec mon
homologue le ministre freezer on a eu 5
rencontres de travail depuis ma
nomination et à aucun moment cette
information à l'effet qu'il y aurait eu
une entente déjà existante convenu ne
nous a été communiquée alors je vais
laisser le gouvernement canadien
préciser ce qu'il en est concernant
cette information mais de toute façon le
résultat c'est que vous êtes satisfaite
au gouvernement on a entendu monsieur
Legault vous êtes très content on est
très très content parce que vraiment
c'était le noyau dur de nos demandes on
a cinq demandes qu'on a déposées et
réitérer au gouvernement depuis cet
automne et vraiment antérieurement aussi
on avait des demandes mais la demande la
plus difficile à obtenir c'était celle
de la renégociation de l'entente sur les
tiers pays et on a accès notre stratégie
sur la visite du président Biden parce
qu'il y avait là vraiment une fenêtre
d'opportunité idéale pour faire en sorte
de finaliser cette négociation qui
perdurerait d'année en année je rappelle
pour le bénéfice des spectateurs le ce
que l'on fait c'est qu'on prend
l'entente sur le tiers bien sûr et on
l'étend à toute la frontière de sorte
quelqu'un qui se présente au chemin
Roxane ou ailleurs dans les bois pourra
être sera refoulé aux États-Unis parce
qu'il était un seul américain donc c'est
ça l'idée du tiers est-ce que par
ailleurs il y a pas un danger pour vous
avez entendu les avocats qui s'occupent
des de l'immigration monsieur richols
s'occupe des réfugiés eux sont
catastrophiques ce soir comment on
pourra les rassurer de ne pas je
voudrais souligner que la gestion de la
frontière avec les États-Unis ça relève
du gouvernement fédéral donc c'est lui
qui assure le contrôle de la gestion
puis qui assure également la sécurité le
long de la frontière moi rassuré par le
fait que dorénavant la voix pour entrer
au Canada en tant que demandeur d'asile
sera la voie régulière et non la voix
irrégulière il était anormal que une
telle quantité on parle de plusieurs
dizaines de milliers de demandeurs
d'asile puissent traverser entrée au
Canada via une mécanique irrégulière on
a des règles pour ça on les encadre
c'est passage des demandeurs d'asile et
voilà ça passe par les voies régulières
en contrepartie le Canada accepté
d'accueillir 15000 réfugiés ou est-ce
que vous avez des détails là-dessus ce
que le Québec va en prendre que comment
ça va le fédéral nous a confirmé
effectivement ce nombre de 15000
demandeurs d'asile moi j'ai indiqué que
le Québec avait déjà fait sa part
amplement avec les demandeurs d'asile
qui sont arrivés au cours des derniers
mois donc on demande à ce que c'est
15000 personnes additionnelles soit
redirigées vers d'autres provinces
considérant que la capacité
notre capacité d'accueil est déjà
atteinte voire dépasser donc voilà c'est
15000 personnes additionnelles il n'y a
pas il y a pas possibilité pour le
québecs quand on parle de capacité
d'accueil il s'agit d'un toit il s'agit
d'un accès à des services
gouvernementaux donc quel que soit la
langue parlée si la capacité d'accueil
n'est pas là elle n'est pas là donc ça
suit cette logique là on va suivre ce
dossier la Christine Frechette ministre
de l'Immigration merci de nous voir
merci à vous au revoir